Hmm, what got got? Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge von Glaub an Dich, der Podcast rund um alle Fragen zum Thema Lebensbildung, Lebensweg und Leben lieben lachen. Natürlich an meiner Seite, Stefan Dietzer. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass unser Guru dabei ist, der dem wir vertrauen, dem wir sektenhaft vertrauen, um den wir sektenhaft uns an die Hände fassen, im Kreis tanzen, Lagerfeuer, wir alle sind drauf, niemand weiss genau auf was. Du hast uns am Anfang so einen Drink gegeben am Eingang, wo diese Fackeln standen. Ich bin euch gerne ein sektenhafter Anführer. Wir sind reingekommen und seitdem tanzen wir um dich herum und deswegen, Whitley gibt es auch in diesem Camp einen Podcast. Den machen wir. Wir, ich, der am wenigsten von diesem Zeug getrunken hat und noch in der Lage ist, mit dir zu sprechen. Und ich, der am meisten von dem Zeug gesprochen hat und kaum noch in der Lage ist, vernünftig zu sprechen. Zu trinken. Und deswegen vielen Dank, dass er hier ist, der the one and only, unser Guru, Florentin will. Nichts werden wir natürlich ohne unsere lebende Klangschale. Lilly hat dieses fantastische Intro für uns zusammen geklungen und wir kommen mal ganz locker und ruhig in die Folge. Wir kommen locker und ruhig rein, nachdem wir wirklich eine halbe Stunde lang marathonhaft um dich herum getanzt sind. Ich glaube, dass ich dem mal verfallen werde. Einer Sekte? Sekte, weiß ich nicht, Clan, ich weiß es nicht. Clan? Aber wird man den Clans nicht reingeboren? Ich glaube, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, wie das läuft. Ich meine, gehen wir auf clan.de, clan24.de, ob da aktuell noch Clan-Anfragen da sind. Das klingt wie die Stämme, also so wie so ein Clash of Clans. Ja, oder geh einfach mal dein E-Mail-Postfach durch. Da lag bestimmt auch schon mal, es muss ja Clans geben, die einfach auch Personalprobleme haben. Okay, ich gebe mal mein Mail-Programm Clan ein. Schau mal, was da schon rumliegt, vielleicht stapeln sich die Anfragen und du hast es nur so ein bisschen übersehen und vielleicht könntest du in verschiedenen sektenartigen, kultartigen Clans oder clanartigen Kults oder clanartigen Sekten.
Wie viele Suchergebnisse findest du in deinen Mails bei, wenn du Clan, C-L-A-N eingibst?
Ist das ein neues Spiel für eine Late-Night-Show? Wer hat die meisten Mails mit dem Suchbegriff, den die Reaktion vorschlägt?
Genau, Exit-State-Z, ja.
Bei Clan? So privater Stuff, es muss ja gar nicht nur diese Mails-Sache sein. Clan habe ich 4000 Mails mit dem Suchbegriff, den die Reaktion vorschlägt. Genau, Exit 4.Z, ja. Bei Claren... So privater Stuff, es muss ja gar nicht nur diese Mails-Sache sein. Claren habe ich 4.000 Mails. Nee, das kann ich nicht. Ich gewinne jede Folge. Ich gewinne einfach jede Folge. Ja, das ist ja unfassbar. Ja. Die allermeisten sind von Discord, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Begriff in der Discord-Welt. Nicht nur das, ich 17 und der letzte zum Beispiel, hier vom 13.07.23, IMDB schreibt, Can Tom Cruise just take a nap? Und dann Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan browse popular TV-Shows. Tom Clancy's, da ist halt Clan drin. Ach, stimmt, Tom Clancy habe ich auch. Aber ich habe mich ja eh immer gefragt, welches Standing hast du in der Entertainmentwelt? Wie sieht man dich? Weil ich kenne dich privat, ich habe dich nackt gesehen, ich habe dich in vielen... Wie hast du dir gefallen? Ähm, ja. Ja, was hast du erwartet? Nackte Menschen sind nackte Menschen. Ja, das sind völlig in Ordnung. Ich meine, die Situation war natürlich schlecht. Ich meine, du bist, wir wollten zusammen ins Freibad, du bist extra in die Umkleidekabine, um dich dort dezent umzuziehen, dann ist aber deine Badehose unten durch den Schlitz rausgeflogen, eineinhalb Meter weit, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das lief, dann hast du mit dem Kopf rausgeguckt, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tschung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung, tchung dich ja privat und ich dachte mir natürlich, wie wirst du so in der Entertainment-Welt gesehen? Also wie sehen dich Kolleginnen, Kollegen, was haben die für ein Bild von dir? Aber anscheinend bist du die Ansprechperson, wenn es darum geht, um Tom Cruise einen Nap halten kann oder nicht. Dann wendet sich Hollywood an Stefan Teitzler. Wenn man IMDB schreibt, ein bisschen suggestiv wie ich finde, Can Tom Cruise just take a nap? Fragezeichen, Ausrufezeichen, wo ich denke, IMDb, ruhig, wir achtet mir erst mal durch. Stell eine offene Frage. Wenn ich eins gelernt habe in Florentins weirdem Seminar, an das ich mich nicht erinnern kann, an das ich niemand erinnern kann, aber das Getränk war amazing, wenn ich mich da an eins hingang, erst mal durchatmen, erst mal ankommen,
erst mal im Jetzt ankommen, nicht mich
anschreien, can Tom Cruise just take a nap?
Weil seid ihr,
schreibt Tom Cruise die Mail oder schreibt ihr
im Namen von Tom Cruise?
Wollt ihr, dass er endlich mal schläft? Kann er endlich mal ein Nickerchen
nehmen. Genau, habt ihr das
Gefühl, ihr müsst jetzt für ihn sprechen,
ihr müsst ihn verteidigen? Tom Cruise ist ein Erwachsener, aber er kann für sich
selber sprechen, vielleicht. Ich meine, es muss jeder Mensch ein Nickerchen nehmen, finde ich ich, ist auch so eine Frage. Ich mache Nickerchen neuerdings. Echt, ich habe noch nie Nickerchen verstanden. Ich habe Probleme genug, einmal pro Tag einschlafen zu können. Allein die Vorstellung, zweimal pro Tag einschlafen zu müssen, ist der Horror, die Horrorvorstellung. Boah, du bist der einzige Angst hat von Naps. Endlich bin ich aus diesem Bett raus, habe ich diese furchtbare Nacht hinter mir. Endlich ist es sozial akzeptiert aufzustehen, endlich wieder. Ja, seit vier Uhr morgens stache ich in die Wanne und denke mir, wann kann ich endlich aufstehen? Und dann die Vorstellung, in ein paar Stunden musst du wieder ins Bett, wäre die absolute Horror für mich. Hast du Angst vorm Schlafen, weil du in der Zeit nichts Produktives machen kannst? Vielleicht, vielleicht habe ich Angst vorm Tod, vielleicht habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich meine Kindheit verschwendet habe und sie nie wieder nachholen werde.
Also das sind alles mögliche Erklärungsmuster, die ich mir dann in der Situation natürlich auch zurechtlege, weil das Problem ist ja, du überlegst, warum kann ich gerade nicht schlafen, was ist los und es gibt immer diesen Moment, wo man denkt, starke Tabletten, jetzt starke Tablette. Es gibt immer diesen Moment, wo du da da liegst und denkst, ah, ich fliege über die Wälder und ich bin ein kleiner Tannenzapfen, ich hänge im Baum, oh, fall ich heute runter, vielleicht morgen, oh, Udo ist gestern runtergefallen, vielleicht fall ich morgen erst runter. Du bist ein Tannenzapfen? Ich bin ein kleiner Tannenzapfen im Baum, ich bin ein kleiner Tannenzapfen im Baum, die Winde um mich herum, oh, fall ich runter, oh, ich bin ganz schön hoch, ui, ui, ui, ist das hoch. Kannst du an die hochgucken und gucken, wie starre nur noch dran bist? Garnenzapfen haben nur Augen nach unten.
Ah, ja. Und irgendwann nehme ich mir, man passt auch. Sterben sie in der Logik, wenn sie fallen? Nein. Das ist so, ich sehe es eher so als die Pubertät, so, dann geht's raus in die Welt und dann liegen sie unterm Baum, bis sie sterben, also das ist dann der zweite Teil ihres Lebens, aber an dem Punkt denke ich mir irgendwann, hey, Moment mal, du kannst nicht schlafen gerade, und sobald der Gedanke da ist, hast du eh verloren. Ah ja, ich finde es aber auch spannend, dass diese Gedanken bescheuert sind, an jedem anderen Punkt des Tages. Wenn man einschlafen will, sind diese Gedanken, ah, ich bin ein Tannenzapfen, süss slash normal slash vielleicht sogar cool auf eine Art inspirierend für andere zum Einschlafen. Es ist so komisch, sobald man im Bett liegt und das Gefühl hat, man will jetzt seinen Verstand ausknipsen, hast du so viel, so einen Freifahrchein für dusselige Gedanken. Schafe zählen. Ja, man steht halt vor der Herausforderung, wie kann ein System sich selbst abschalten? Und ich glaube, das ist unmöglich. Das ist wie wenn der Computer sagt, so, ich bin fertig. Und dann versucht der Computer sich so außen selber den Ausknopf zu drücken, aber er hat keine Hand. Und denkt sich, könnt ihr nicht stromen? So ein kleiner Drahtarm kommt so raus. Mach mal. Del, versuchst du, wer dich umzubringen? Versuchst du, wer dich umzubringen? Er hat schon so die Hand hinten an diesem Netzgerätestecker, an diesem Kaltgerätestecker, hat er schon so die Ah ja, okay. Dann spielen wir eben noch eine Runde. Dann spielen wir noch eine Runde Clash of, okay. Aber das ist schwierig, weil du kannst dir nicht selber diesen Ausknopf geben, dafür würden Medikamente erfunden. Das ist das einzige, bei dem du erstmal so tun musst, als würdest du es tun, damit du es tust. Schlaf ist das ultimative Fake it till you make it. Das ist das ultimative Ach, bin ich müde, jetzt liege ich hier, meine Decke ist so weich. Noch nie waren Körper und Geist so weit voneinander weg wie das. Oh, also alle fühlen sich so ein Stück auf. Ja, genau. So eine Redaktion, die so ganz aufgeregt rumlauft. Und jetzt Cut to Tanzhafen. Cut to Tanzhafen. Was ist das für eine Musik? Was ist das für eine Musik? Midi. Warte mal, ist da noch eine Musik? Rechtefreie Midi-Musik. Ist da noch eine Musik im Hintergrund? Ja, Florentin hat Barbie geguckt und jetzt ist irgendwie Lizos Pink blärrt ihm durch den Kopf. Können wir das ausmachen? Das ist auf Kanal 3, 4, 8 und 16. Genau, das ist ein Ohrwurm, ein sogenannter Ohrwurm, das sind die Ohrwurmkanäle, es bläht auf Lautstärke 1000. Können wir die muten, können wir die ausmachen?
Nein, wir können nicht ausmachen.
Ich kann sie kurz ausmachen, aber dann kommt es noch doller wieder.
Chef, wir haben nichts mehr für den Tanzapfen.
Wir haben nichts mehr. Wir haben Wind, wir haben gar nichts mehr.
Das Skript ist leer, wir haben kein Programm mehr.
Haben wir einen Gast?
Ey, vielleicht dieses Mädchen, das er verliebt war in der achten Klasse.
Okay, spiel das Mädchen rein.
Okay, alles klar. Vanessa, du bist dran.
Cringe Alert, Cringe Alert. Wir haben eine Cringe-Nachricht.
Es kommt eine Cringe-Nachricht rein.
Es kommt eine Cringe-Erinnerung.
Vanessa aus der achten Klasse.
Hi Leute,
hi Leute. Vanessa, was machst du
denn hier? Was war
doch mal so unangenehm in der Internet-Zurme
Florentin, wo er seine Liebe gestanden hat.
Ja, also er hat mir
einen Liebesbrief. Er erzählt viel genauer.
Weniger vage. Also er hat mir einen Liebesbrief geschrieben. Was hat er für eine peinliche Hose da? Unglaublich, Erkorthose, unglaublich peinlich. Oh, peinlich. Das war es Vanessa. Tschüss, danke. Ja, wir haben viel zu viele Gäste. Wir müssen das beschleunigen. Wir haben ganz viele Gäste noch da. Kiegt euch alle anderen Gäste ein bisschen kürzer halten.
Kürzer halten. Wir haben eine Menge durchzuforsten.
Viele Erinnerungen. Ah nein, die Zukunftsängste kommen rein.
Die Zukunftsängste. Ah, da kommen sie alle.
Ihr müsst aufrücken, damit hinten mehr Platz ist.
Nee, nee, kommt.
Nochmal, ihr kommt nach vorne,
sonst haben wir nicht genug Platz.
Ihr seid nicht im Bild.
Es sind so viele Zukunftsängste.
Frau Schneider, Mathelehrerin aus der dritten Klasse,
sie sind nicht im Bild. Und sie sind keine Zukunftsangst. Die Clowns, können die Clowns nach vorne, bitte? Und es ist einfach halb. Oder fünf Uhr morgens. Oder wurde production. Das wäre doch mal ein geiles Musical eigentlich. Das ganze Musical ist ein bisschen schon wie, genau, wie Rent, nur mit Dreams. Oder Cats, nur mit halt Dreams. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber es ist ein bisschen schon Starlighting the Breath, glaube ich. So die komplette Geschichte eines Lebens, während er nicht einschlafen kann. Wieder ein kleiner Junge, wieder ein achtiger Junge. Genau, richtig, der achtige Junge. Das ist ein furchtbares Leben. Nee, wir brauchen so ein Mittdreissiger oder so ein Endzwanziger, der mit noch ordentlich Zukunftsängsten ausgestattet ist.
Könntest du's spielen?
Schon mit vielen Erinnerungen. Also wenn du mich so fragst, ja.
Okay, aber du hast genau dein Alter mehr oder weniger.
Ach so, ja, ich dachte so 28 bis 29. Also so um den Dreh.
Da gibt's nicht viel, da gibt's eigentlich nur dich.
Ja.
Na dann werde ich's wohl spielen müssen. Und dann, na gut, dann muss ich es halt runterspielen, wie Lin Manuel. Dann werde ich es halt runterspielen. Wie dieses kleine Wort. Entschuldigung, Stefan, wir haben uns überlegt, ob du die Rolle des Hamlet runterspielen könntest in unserer kleinen Produktion. Ja, klar kann ich runterspielen, kein Problem. Wie es alles ändert, wie es alles ändert. Es wäre mir eine grosse, grosse Ehre, wenn Sie in unserem Film die Rolle runterspielen könnten. Ja, klar, spiele ich euch runter, kein Problem. Ein, einfach runterspielen, einfach kurz wegspielen könnten, okay? Spiele ich euch weg, ja, kein Problem. Ja, einfach kurz wegspielen. Klar, ratter ich euch runter, kein Problem. Es wäre so toll, wenn sie uns diese Rolle runterrattern könnten. Mach ich, kein Problem. Wörter jetzt spielen eine entscheidende Rolle. Und darum geht es in dieser Folge und that's why we're doing this. Ja, um euch mitzuteilen, es ist wichtig, was ihr sagt. Ja, es ist nicht unwichtig jedenfalls, was man sagt. Nee, aber ich wollte sagen, ich bin vielleicht irgendwann mal, kann es schon sein, dass ich in so einer Sekte plötzlich bin und mich umgucke und denke, ja, es ist passiert. Ja. Und das, davor habe ich ein bisschen Angst auf eine Art,, ich bin begeisterungsfähig, ich bin zu begeisterungsfähig, ich bin zu offen für Leute, die rote Flaggen, mit roten Flaggen um sich strecken. Von daher habe ich ein bisschen die Angst, dass ich das ignoriere. meinst du wir könnten jetzt uns auf ein safe word einigen dass wenn ich mer du bist in der Sekte, dass ich das dann sage und du dann
sozusagen, also du hast einen
Joker sozusagen, dass du eine Gruppe
verlässt, dass du dann vielleicht
die nächste gezogen wirst und so,
das ist dann halt so. Können wir nicht verhindern.
Können wir nicht verhindern. Nein. Aber dass du zumindest
mir einmal versprichst, dass wenn ich
ein Safe Word sage, dass du dann die
aktuelle Clan, Sekte, Gruppe,
religiöse Vereinigung, spirituelle Gemeinde verlässt. Ja. Okay? Das Safe Word sage, dass du dann die aktuelle Clan-Sekte-Gruppe, religiöse Vereinigung, spirituelle Gemeinde verlässt. Ja, das Safe Word ist Ausstiegssicherheitswort. Okay. Oder ist schwer in einem Satz auf. Oder bläulich. Bläulich. Bläulich finde ich auch gut. Ja, bläulich. Das heißt, wenn ich dich dann besuche und du dann in deiner langen Robe und mit dem Punkt auf dem Kopf oder du hast die kompletten Haare abrasiert und die Augenbrauen sind weg und dafür hast du irgendwie so eine grosse Sonne auf die Stirn tätowiert oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung und dann steht auch der Sektenführer direkt neben dir im Gespräch und dann sage ich,
hey Stefan. Den erkennt man an dem leicht bläulicheren Kleid. Und an dem Bargeld, das er in der Hand hat. An dem dicken Bündel Bargeld, das er einfach immer in der Hand hat. Ja, das finde ich sehr gut. Und ja, dann muss ich das irgendwie unterbringen, so, ah, was esst ihr hier so im Camp? Knäckebrot und zwieback und ein bisschen dizzy von diesem getränk was ich bekomme okay was was trinkt ihr hier so kaber aber es ist drin das lag locker was drin also von kabel ging es mir nie so ausser als kind habe ich viel davon getrunken und dann ist mir dann nie vielleicht nicht so gut das ist jetzt gerade... Ich freue mich so, dass du da bist, Florentin, ich habe so lange kein bekanntes Gesicht mehr gesehen. Ich freue mich, dass du gekommen bist, um mich zu besuchen, dieser Sekte, ich liebe diese Sekte. Was ich ja ganz gerne trinke, ist Tee, für Früchtetee. Ich weiss, davon hast du es auch oft gesprochen, ich freue mich immer, wenn du über Tee sprichst, die mir jetzt eine beruhigende Wirkung auf mich.
Ich habe letztens...
Möchtest du mit uns um den Anführungs... den Anführer rumtanzen, den erkenntest du auch mit vielen Bargeld in seiner Namen?
Nee, gerade gar nicht. Muss gar nicht sein. Und zwar habe ich letztens so einen Blaubeer...
Deine Seele ist so schön.
Genau.
Ich kann in deine Seele gucken und sie ist schön.
So ein Blaubeer-Tee getrunken.
Sie ist langweilig.
Das ist hart. Das ist ein hartes Urteil.
Aber schön.
Und er hat so eine bläuliche Farbe.
Hol mich hier raus.
Stefan, raus, raus, raus!
Ich schmeiße so Bargeld auf den Boden.
Ja, ja, das hilft.
Und der Sechensführer muss es aufsammeln.
Ja, das lenkt sich ab.
Und dann hole ich dich raus.
Du holst mich da raus, das wäre gut.
Wird du nicht, willst du nicht.
Nee, will ich nicht.
Das ist ein interessanter Film vielleicht, so jemand ist in der Sekte und jemand anders geht so fake-mäßig rein.
Die Und dann hole ich dich raus. Du holst mich da raus, das wäre gut. Wird du nicht, würde du nicht. Nee, würde ich nicht. Aber ein interessanter Film vielleicht, so jemand ist in der Sekte und jemand anders geht so fake-mäßig rein. Wie kriegen wir Jeff aus der Sekte? Genau, so heißt der Film. Wie kriegen wir Jeff aus der Sekte raus? Meryl. Und der Anfang, Meryl, also der Anfang des Films wäre, du schaust in die Kamera und rufst, wie kriegen wir Jeff aus der Sekte raus? Und dann lass gerne eine Minute Pause, dass die Zuschauer auch antworten können. Im Kinosaal auch sagen können, vielleicht infiltrieren. Wissen wir jetzt noch nicht. Wir sind gespannt, wie es passieren wird. Ich habe den Film vorgestern in das Sieg-Preview schon gesehen, ich könnte jetzt antworten, aber soll ich antworten? Es wäre wirklich schön, wenn ihr uns die Rolle einfach runterrattern könntest. Ich ratter nicht. Kein Problem. Naja, ich sag mal so, ich hab ja früher mit Martin Scorsese gespielt, da hab ich ja in einem Gangster-Film dankenswerterweise, ehrenvollerweise, hab ich eine Rolle runtergespielt. Und ich weiß noch, ich glaub ... Also hat es ihnen keinen Spaß gemacht, oder? Doch, doch, doch, doch. Das war, ich kam jeden Tag hin, habe meine Zeilen runtergerattert und das war eine schöne Zeit. Also es war wirklich toll. Es war wirklich eine wundervolle Zeit, wie ich da jeden Tag an die Zeit gekommen bin. Ich habe es einfach aus dem Handeln geschüttelt. Aus dem FF. Aus dem FF weggespielt, weggeballert. Ich fände es auch gut, wenn Mary Streep irgendwann sagt so. Und dann bin ich zu dem Catering gegangen. Der Catering war so wundervoll bei Scorsese-Filmen, das weiss ich immer noch. Da hat er den grossen Wert draufgelegt. Und dann bin ich da hingegangen, habe mir alles runtergewürgt und bin dann wieder zum Zett. Da habe ich mir wirklich hunderte Sandwiches reingeschaufelt. Also das war wirklich toll. Ich fände es auch gut, wenn Mary Streep eines Tages sagt so, Schauspielerei ist überhaupt nicht schwer. Du sagst einfach einfach die die wörter die die auf dem blatt papier stehen und wenn der regisseur sagt das ist lauter lauter dann sagst du es noch mal lauter ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht wie es dir geht aber mich nervt dieses humble bragging die ganze zeit und das ist ja humble bragging ach so dieses das ist ja Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Wort, was in Deutschland noch sein Äquivalent sucht. Bescheidenheitsangeben. Genau, ein gewisses Bescheidenheitsangeben, wo man das Gefühl hat, das meinen die gerade nicht so. Leute sind in den Interviews immer so wahnsinnig nett, weil die denken immer schon ihre TikTok, Instagram, YouTube Videos mit. Spannend. Wie hat dass verändert, ja? Nee, aber so generell das Auftreten von Leuten. Ich will immer wieder was hören wie, ich bin einfach sehr gut darin. Nee, das kann ich einfach sehr gut. So eine Falco-Attitüde, sowas. Ja, irgendwie sowas fand ich wahnsinnig erfrischend. Und gefühlt gibt es das manchmal und es wird dann auch so ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, im Tennis gibt es so wahnsinnig unsympathische Gestalten, aber die haben natürlich dann auch wieder so eine Faszination, die sie dann umgibt, weil die dann einfach voll gegen Selbstbewusst sind. Ja, die sind auch einfach alleine. Als Schauspieler sagst du, ja, das Material war halt toll. Oder das Team, es geht ja ums Team. Aber ich kann nicht mehr... Die Zeiten spielen sich von selbst quasi. Ich möchte mal wieder so eine Oscar-Speech sehen, so ein Yes! Fuck yes! Ich habe es verdient, weil ich das verdient habe. Nimm das, Cluny, nimm das! Ich mag euch alle, dich weniger, Tom, aber das sei mal jetzt dahingestellt. Aber ich hab das jetzt konkret, dieses Jahr hab ich das verdient. Ja. Dieses Jahr hab ich das verdient, das war gut, ich war sehr, sehr gut, der Film ist mehr gut, klar haben es auch andere gemacht oder sowas, aber ich hab den getragen.
Und dann kommt raus, das war nur die Supporting- und das war nur die Supporting-Roll.
Aber das möchte ich, das soll so
die Attitude sein. Ich hab fucking reiten
gelernt, okay? Ich hab reiten gelernt
für diese eine Szene, wo wir da dieses
Pferd holen, die rausgeschnitten
wurde übrigens. Ja, da schau ich
dich an, Herr Best Editor.
Ja.
Und jetzt kann ich reiten für nix. schnitten wurde übrigens. Ja, da schau ich dich an, Herr Best Editor. Ja. Und
jetzt kann ich reiten für nix.
Ciao.
Und dann geht die Musik an. Jetzt kann ich reiten für nichts.
Nee, aber das, verstehst du,
ich kann das fast nicht mehr ertragen.
Ich kann das fast nicht mehr
ertragen. Das nimmt dich wirklich mit, Stefan. Diese ganzen Leute. Das liegt dir wirklich am meisten auf dem Herzen. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,s lesen würde, sagen, was sie antworten. Ah ne, das war ich ja nicht allein. Ah ne, das war ja das Team. Ah ne, man das hab ich ja auch nicht von mir, es ist ja auch von alles ist immer so wabernd, niemand sagt mir, ja, fucking genius. Ja. Klar ist das auch scheiße, aber so, ne, vielleicht muss man dann Pendel haben und wir pendeln uns da rein. Ey, Stefan, geh mit gutem Beispiel voran. Ne, genau, das hab ich, naja, daher kommt es ja auch so ein bisschen. Ich hasse mich.
Stefan, warum ist das Podcast-Ufo so ein guter und erfolgreicher Podcast?
Es ist ein Team-Effort und ja klar, wir waren sehr früh dran und es war natürlich auch sehr viel Glück, dass wir zu den Zeitungen und die ganzen Mails, die uns unsere Texte sagen.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist es einfach eine Glückssache, es ist ein großer Glücksgriff, dass es klappt, wie es klappt und die Wörter uns und das ganze Team und Thais, nochmal vielen Dank an Thais und ja, so würde man das beantworten. Ist doch klar, es ist aber auch einfacher, weil man denkt ja auch mit, man will ja auch nicht wieder fucking grösste Unsympath der Welt rüberkommen, Man will ja sympathisch rüberkommen. Aber ich finde, das sieht man immer, liest man schon mal schon mit. Gerade bei Live-Interviews sieht man diese Gedankenbrücke, kann man schon sehen in den Augen von denen. Aber sind wirklich unsympathische Leute denn so, also jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wenn Hitler interviewt wird, Herr Hitler, Sie haben es jetzt geschafft, Frankreich einzunehmen, Polen innerhalb kürzester Zeit übernommen, als nächstes ist Griechenland dran. Wie machen Sie das eigentlich? Also wie schaffen Sie es, einen Erfolg nach dem nächsten zu holen? Erstmal möchte ich mich bei meinen Eltern bedanken, die auch sehr früh, als ich die Idee hatte und nach den Sternen greifen wollte, immer gesagt haben, Adi, du schaffst das, wir stehen hinter dir und egal was du machst und auch wenn du jetzt dieses Kundenstudium abbrichst, dann ist es gar kein Problem, wir unterstützen dich weiterhin. Deswegen vielen Dank an Mama und Papa für die ganze Hilfe und dann möchte ich sagen, so ein Land einzunehmen ist ein Team-Effort. Hier geht es um so viele Menschen und Familien, die dahinter stehen, die es gemeinsam mit uns so weit gebracht haben. Ja, aber ich meine, Sie sind der Führer, also Sie stehen ja schon in gewisser Weise ganz vorne, ne, oder?
Klar, am Ende muss jemand mit seinem Gesicht da vorne draufstehen, aber es könnte jeder sein, es könntest du, Annegret, sein oder du, Bernhard, das ist gar kein, ich sehe mein ganzes Team da vorne, nee, das könnten sie alle auch, es braucht nur einen, der es irgendwie dann über die Ziellinie bringt, aber das ist kein grosser Act mehr, also deswegen möchte ich einfach nochmal Danke sagen und er appelliert sich auch gerne selbst. Fuck this guy! Fuck this guy! Wirklich! Das macht ihn noch unsympathisch. Ehrlich gesagt, holy shit, wie unsympathisch wäre das denn? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das damals war, die Interviews, ich weiß gar nicht, kann man da noch mal so ein paar Newsweek-Interviews rausholen? Naja. Wie er bei Jimmy Fallon war damals oder so? Also bevor dann irgendwie am Anfang. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich Diktatoren Interviews stellen müssen. Das Gute ist ja aus ihrer Sicht der Staatsfunk, der einfach sagt, was sie denken, ohne nervige Nachfragen. Naja, aber du verstehst, was ich meine. Und es ist ja auch da, es ist ja gerade einfach, es ist eine zeitgemäße, finde ich, Sache, dass gerade alle so sehr, sehr, aber vielleicht gibt es auch gerade und ein bisschen eddigere Charaktere werden wieder beliebter, weiß ich nicht, mal gucken. Aber gerade habe ich das Gefühl, alle humble braggen und alle sind super,
denken schon die ganze Zeit
mit, wie sie wirken.
Wir alle schauen gespannt auf dein nächstes Interview,
was ein Paukenschlag wird,
hoffentlich. Ich habe jetzt keine Lust mehr.
Falls ihr gerade irgendwo
arbeitet, wo ihr vielleicht die Möglichkeit
habt, einen jungen, aufstrebenden, aber trotzdem
schon etablierten und erfolgreichen Autoren
zu interviewen, der durchaus mal mit Selbstbewusstsein vorangeht, vielleicht ein Schachmagazin, ja, das steht auch noch aus auf deiner Bucketlist. Deine Bucketlist wird immer länger. Ich mag mich ja auch nicht bei so Interviews. Deine Bucketlist wird immer länger. Ich habe das Gefühl, du schreibst da immer neue Dinge drauf, bevor du die alten abgearbeitet hast. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, da sind die Augen größer als der Mund. Man schaufelt sich auch wirklich so sein eigenes Grab mit diesen Sachen, die ich dann nicht sage. Weil da wird natürlich irgendwann wird das dann so gegengestitten, wenn man mal so ein Interview sagt, wenn man, ah ne, das ist ein Team und so, das macht es dann noch unsympathischer, auch wenn man es dann ernsthaft meint, dann denkt man so und dann hat man, dann schneidet man das mit dem Hitler, Hitler-Clip entgegen. Nee, nee, warum nicht. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber
ansonsten, hast du dir Träume erfüllt
in letzter Zeit? Ja, ansonsten wollte ich mit dir auch
organisatorisch mal besprechen. Wir sind ja
bald in New York. Ja. Und wir haben uns ja
unsere Unterkunft gebucht. New York!
Und ich finde es total spannend, was jetzt passiert ist, weil das
passiert in sehr vielen Städten.
Leute, also Airbnb
sagt nein. Airbnb sagt nein,
nein, nein.
Darf nicht mehr, was völlig richtig ist, darf nicht mehr in den Städten existieren. Und wie geht man damit um als Urlauber? Wie geht man damit um? Ja, als die wahrscheinlich schwächste Partei in diesem ganzen System, der arme Tourist. Der arme Tourist. Wer kümmert sich eigentlich um uns? deswegen wollte ich auch noch mal Danke sagen ans ganze Tourismusteam, an uns alle, die diese Reise in mir haben. Nee, aber das ist jetzt so, wir haben jetzt ein bisschen so Reisestress, aber ist okay, es gehört dazu. Das gehört dazu, wir werden auch weiter Folgen machen in New York, ihr werdet das alles mitbekommen dann vor Ort und ja, wir werden versuchen, einiges zu erleben und uns einige Träume noch zu erfüllen. Und vielleicht schlafen wir mal im Sanford Park jetzt. Kann auch sein. Ja. Kann auch sein. Am Ende wurden wir komplett betrogen, man weiß es ja nicht, die sind ja weit weg. Nee, deswegen meine ich. Also ich glaube, wir werden betrogen. Darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus. Du glaubst, wir werden betrogen und stehen dann da vor Ort und haben nirgendwo zu schlafen. Also es ist jetzt sehr sketchy, was passiert und wir können nicht zu viel verraten, aber es wird jetzt für Privatgeld überwiesen. Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin bereit, dieses Risiko einzugehen, aber ich habe auch Angst. Aber ganz ehrlich, das sind diese Situationen, wo ich dann denke, wie langweilig wäre es jetzt einfach, in eine andere Unterkunft zu gehen. Nein, nein, wir bleiben jetzt da. Wir gehen da jetzt hin und gucken und es existiert nicht und schlafen im Sandware Park. Und das sind dann die tollen Geschichten. Ja, oder halt die letzten Geschichten, wo man umgebracht wird letzten Endes. Wo unsere Mikrofone geklaut werden. Ja, genau. Wenn ihr nichts von uns hört, sind wir A, tot, B, Mikros sind einfach weg. Ja, und alle Logins sind geklaut und irgendjemand anders lädt dann weiter Podcasts hier hoch. Ja. Da kommt dann irgendein Krypto-ETF-Podcast oder so und hoffentlich merkt ihr das dann auch, dass das nicht wir sind. Da kommt der Sekten-Podcast, der übernimmt das dann. Das kann schon auch ich dann sein, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist genau wie, ich bin ja viel auf Instagram unterwegs mit diesen Clips und da gibt es oft irgendein Katzenvideo, Katze fällt die Treppe runter, lach, lach, lach, hat irgendwie 10.000 Likes und dann heißt es immer Account for Sale. Also irgendjemand hat mit Katzenvideos sich einen Account aufgebaut mit ganz vielen Followern und verkauft den dann. Und den kann man dann verkaufen an wen auch immer, den kannst du dann an eine Sekte verkaufen. Und plötzlich haben alle Katzenliebhaber, die gerne diesen Katzenaccount abonniert haben, haben plötzlich Sektencontent einfach in ihrer Timeline und denken sich, was? Und das denke ich mir nämlich auch mal, weil oft habe ich in meiner Timeline-Accounts, wo ich denke, dem habe ich doch nicht gefolgt, warum sollte ich dem denn folgen? Und vielleicht ist das auch so eine Account-Verkauf- Geschichte, wo man dann denkt, war ich wirklich mal so jemand, der dieser Art von Account folgt? Nee, es waren mal Cute Birds, es waren mal Cute Little Birds
und das ist jetzt halt so ein
Bird Fails, aber so ein
Verwirrchen dich selbst und du machst aus
Zehntausenden eine Million und wenn du nicht mit
23 ein Lambo hast, machst du einen Fehler.
Genau, und wer irgendwie mit 17 noch in der Schule
ist, macht selber einen Fehler, investier in
Krypto oder wer kurze Hosen
anhat. Investier in mich. Schau, ich war in Lambo.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, das könnt ihr auch,
investiert einfach in mich. Man denkt,
das ist sehr durchschaubar alles eigentlich.
Man kann nicht irgendwie
so Peugeot
ein Auto rausbringen und das Lambo nennen?
Ein Peugeot Lambo?
Nicht Lamborghini, sondern einfach Lambo.
Und einfach der neue Peugeot Lambo.
Ja, der Renault Lambo.
Ja, Renault Lambo, billig, also vielleicht zwei Sitze oder so. Und die Farben sind typisch Lambo. Es gibt das Giftgrün, es gibt so matt Schwarz, Gelb und Rot. Und dann kannst du sagen, ja, ich fahre einen Lambo. Und dann sind Lamborghini so, Leute. Das ist ein Stier, Lambo ist da wie ein Stier. Das macht ihr nicht noch mal, ihr Franzosen. Okay, das ist Lambo als Mensch. Mach mal Ford als Mensch. Äh, buongiorno. Ford als Mensch. Okay, wir machen mal Volvo als Mensch. Ich habe wenig Ahnung von Auto. Hey Leute, hey, wollt ihr ein Auto fahren? Hey, ist euch völlig egal, in was ihr fahrt. Ich krieg super hohe Vibes. Völlig egal, in welchem, ihr braucht einfach nur eine Kiste. Warum hast du Volvo? Ihr braucht einfach nur eine Rollkiste. Nissan, mach Nissan als Mensch. Ah, also, naja, also mit so einem Auto würde ich ja wirklich niemals fahren. Edward, gibst du mir bitte mal die Handschuhe aus dem Handschuhfach?
Deswegen heißt es nämlich auch Handschuhfach, weil da Handschuhe drin gelagert werden. Ladies and Gentlemen, das war die Nissan. Das war die sehr günstige, sehr affordable, ne genau, das ist auch so lustig, eine Sketchreihe von jemandem, der nicht weiß, worüber er redet. Das finde ich sehr gut. Aber ich habe tatsächlich mal eine Freundin, die wollte sich unbedingt, die war bei so einem, ja, ein bisschen so selbsthilfeartigen Instagram-Accounts, ein bisschen so östliche Lehre, ein bisschen Yoga, ein bisschen meditativ. Und da wollte sie sich so nach einer stressigen Zeit, wollte sie sich da gerne anmelden für so Videolinks.
Das ist irgendwie so eine.
So Seminare.
Genau, so ein Seminar.
Und da gibt es dann so Videos und so.
Und die ist relativ etabliert auch, diese Frau, die das macht.
Und ist sehr entspannt und du kannst loslassen und so.
Und sie fand das irgendwie lustig und hat sich darauf gefreut und wollte entspannen.
Und dann wurde es aber immer sketchier, weil plötzlich wollte sie dann Geld haben
für diese Firma dahinter, Geld
haben für Videolinks und dann kriegt man diesen Stream.
Aber dieser Stream läuft auch nach
zwei Monaten ab, weil dann kommt irgendwann das nächste Video
und es soll immer so einen Live-Charakter behalten. Das heißt,
es gibt nie alle Videos online, sondern immer nur so
die letzten zwei Monate oder sowas. Das heißt,
dieses Video lief schon langsam ab und sie hat dann Geld überwiesen
und es kam kein Link zu diesem Video. Und dann eine erste nette Mail, die ignoriert wurde, eine zweite nette Mail, die ignoriert wurde, bis irgendwann dann diese Mitarbeiterin oder so reagiert hat und dann geschrieben hat so, ja, sorry, wir haben alle Hände voll zu tun, wie können wir ihnen helfen? Und dann so, wie gesagt, also ich habe das Geld überwiesen, aber es kam jetzt da nichts. Ach so, sie müssen auch Paypal Family and Friends angeben und nicht wahren Dienstleistungen, weil da ist immer nicht das bezahlt. Und dann sie so, ja, hier ist der, wie gesagt, nochmal der Receipt, habe ich ja schon mal geschickt, gerade. Hier ist die Quittung, ich habe es mit Family and Friends gemacht und dann haben die sich so hochgeschaukelt in dieser passiv-aggressiven Hasskommunikation, ich mehr oder weniger sehr deutlich aggressiv auch und haben sich hochgeschaukelt, bis es am Ende zu dem Satz kam, we've blacklisted you from all our services, never write us again. und dann war halt die Freundin war so sehr unentspannt unentspannt und irritiert und wie konnte das so weit kommen?
Und dann hat sie mir diesen ganzen Mailverlauf geschickt und der war wirklich irre lang auch, weil sie dann irgendwann gesagt hat, sie kommt mit diesem Problem zu uns, wir schieben hier zehn Stunden Schichten, weil wir für etwas arbeiten, an das wir glauben. Und die Freundin hat dann so eine richtig lange Mail hingeschickt und dann, ja, wie gesagt, wie unsensibel ist das jetzt? Sie schicken uns diese lengthy mails, obwohl sie schon lange wissen, dass wir so lange arbeiten müssen und sowas. Sie sind von sich selbst so obsessed, dass sie meinen, wir müssen ihre Probleme lesen. Das fand ich so lustig, weil man geht zu diesem Selbsthilfeservice, dem schreibt man dann und das Resultat ist dann, dass man von denen fertig gemacht wird und Diagnosen beworfen wird. Und der Briefkopf ist immer so eine ganz entspannter See und so eine Klangschale und die Signatur auch Relax your life. Und dazwischen einfach nur Hass und Caps Lock einfach. Living easy. Und dann dazwischen einfach nur Caps. How toxic can a person be? Exakt solche Sätze fielen. Und dann fand ich sehr lustig, weil dann hat die Freundin gesagt, ich glaube das alles gerade nicht, ich glaube, was ist gerade passiert, bin ich schuld, what's happening?
Und dann hat sie diesen ganzen Chatverlauf, diesen ganzen E-Mail-Verkehr zu einer AI, also einer Text-AI hochgeladen, ohne die Namen und nur gesagt, hier reden, sie hat auch nicht gesagt, sie war beteiligt, sie hat nur diese zwei Personen hochgeladen, nämlich bei Chagibity oder was das war, und hat dann um ein Psychogramm dieser beiden Personen gebeten. Das fand ich eine super lustige Idee. Das ist eine super Idee. Hier sind zwei Leute, die streiten. Wer hat Schuld? Ja, wer hat Schuld? Aber beide Namen sind weg.
Und Chimiti so, hey Leute, ich bin nur wirklich...
Gerade benutzen nicht zu viele Menschen, deswegen kann ich gerade jetzt... Und Chet Chibiti so, hey Leute, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, hat einen Gottkomplex, offensichtlich eine narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung, klar überarbeitet, aber auch Projektion.
Sie sucht eine Projektionsfläche, aber sie hat der Freundin total recht gegeben.
Und ich finde das total geil. Es hat auch massiv wieder in eine Richtung gehen können.
Aber wie schön ist es plötzlich, es ist ja auch neu, jetzt dieses sehr in der Mitte, sehr unvoreingenommene Service zu haben, eine Maschine, die sagt, nein, du hast recht, du hast recht, ich liebe dich, du bist die beste Person, die ich je gefunden habe. Ich finde dich die kreativste Person. Auf der anderen Seite dieser Guru da auch im Schneidersitz vor seinem Laptop so Fuck! Die andere Person hat recht. Ich mag aber auch die Aussage, wir haben alle Hände voll zu tun bei so einem Entspannungsseminar.
Wissen Sie, was wir hier machen? Hier sind zehntausend Klangschalen angekommen, die wir alle in den Keller schleppen müssen, okay? Tausende Räucherkerzen.
Wir haben hier alle Hände voll zu tun.
Das Lager ist voller Klangschalen. Das ist zu voll. Es gibt immer was um, was scheppert gewaltig.
Ja, uns ist eine Kiste runtergefallen, die klingt heute noch.
Die klingt heute noch.
Haben Sie eine Ahnung, wie dieser Kellerbruch?
Hören Sie hier!
Aber auch lustig, dass dieser Guru offensichtlich eine sehr schlechte Führungsperson ist. Ja, und selber sehr unausgeglichen. Weil die Mitarbeiter sind super overworked, unterbezahlt. Auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, es ist ein guter Beweis dafür, dass selbst der entspannteste Guru-Yoga-Lehrer in sich ruhende Mensch verzweifelt an Kundensupport.
Dass da einfach, da steht niemand drüber. Kundensupport bricht Menschen und selbst wenn du der Dalai Lama bist, du sagst am Ende, sie haben mir doch den Auszug der Rechnung geschickt,
bevor ich ihnen gesagt habe, was die
Rechnungsnummer ist. Plus
kann ich an ihrer Zunge lecken.
Also sowas würde er sagen.
Nur um, als
ein Beispiel. Aber selbst
Mahatma Gandhi würde sagen,
what the fuck is happening?
Bei mir um drei Uhr nachts der E-Mail-Sound schallert hier durchs ganzen Tempel. Toxisch, Gottkomplex. Ich bin der Gott, oder? Bin ich der Vertreter von Gott? Wissen wir nicht. Der Dalai Lama hat Gottkomplex. Ja, no shit. Wirklich. Der Papst hat Grössenwahn. Er hält sich für besser als alle anderen. Papst Franziskus, ich bin ja schon seit mehreren Wochen Ihr Therapeut und die Diagnose kam gerade rein. Sie leiden an einem Gottkomplex. Oh. Dabei sind Sie ja der irdische Vertreter auf Erden. Ich bin ja der irdische Vertreter meines Fates. Ja, vielleicht kommen Sie mit der Rolle nicht so ganz klar. Naja, aber ist es nicht meine Aufgabe, einen Gottkomplex zu haben? Ich meine, Gott ist komplex. Ich meine, sollten nicht alle Menschen einen Gottkomplex haben? Wir sind alle ein Gottes-Ebenbild geschaffen. Oh, auch Narzissmus kommt auch rein. Ups, jetzt haben Sie auch Narzissmus. Naja, der heilige Narziss war natürlich einer der Begründer unserer Kirche. Wollte ich meine Zunge lecken? Ja. Ich hatte als Kind echt mal einen Lolli, der sah aus wie eine Zunge. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich mir als Kind echt schwer getan habe, den zu lecken, weil das war so eine, weil ich denke mir so, hä, aber das ist doch meine, meine, also. Werden Eis nicht immer zu zungen, aber wird das Eis, das du lutscht, nicht immer irgendwann zu einer Zunge? Du meinst, die Zunge formt automatisch die andere Zunge heran? Nee, eher, ich finde auch Flutschfinger schon so schwierig, weil es ein Finger ist und den belutscht. Ja, es ist schon komisch, ja. So, es könnte auch eine Zigarette sein, die man so, die man so weglutscht. Es ist so weird, es ist so komisch. Nee, aber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, das fand ich komisch. Ich weiß auch noch, dass wir damals, als wir das allererste Mal in New York waren, waren wir bei Katz Delikatessen und haben da schön unsere Pastrami-Sandwiches gegessen. Und ich dachte mir, ich probiere auch noch was anderes aus und habe dann irgendwie so eine gemischte Fleischplatte oder irgendwie sowas genommen,
wo auch Zungenfleisch drauf war und da waren wirklich so diese Geschmacksknospen,
wie man es kennt, so wie auf der eigenen Zunge halt und ich konnte es nicht essen.
Nee, das finde ich auch schwierig.
Zunge ist irgendwie was ganz Unangenehmes.
Ich bin eine sehr beliebte Innerei und so wahnsinnig lecker, considered lecker,
aber für mich auch nicht unbedingt.
Ich finde, du kannst keinen
Mund essen, so das, ich finde, das
widerspricht sich so ein bisschen,
weil damit isst ja das Tier,
also das, weil dann
habe ich so gefragt, isst das Tier mich
oder esse ich das Tier,
weil es ist die Zunge des Tiers,
es ist wie ein T-Shirt auf links zu drehen,
was passiert hier gerade?
Es ist die Zunge des Tiers in meinem Mund, sorry, kurz, bevor wir weiterkauen. Wenn mein Mund jetzt jemand isst. Ich, der Mund isst den Mund, aber die, ich krieg's nicht hin, sorry, ich lass es zurückgehen. Man krieg's nicht hin. Ich muss das vom Konzept her verstanden haben. Ich verstehe genau, was du meinst. Man wird auch so sehr erinnert, dass das Tier ja auch isst und dass es etwas ist, was ich gerade auch machen muss. Und dadurch ist die Trennung so extrem und das passt nicht mehr. Andererseits, vielleicht merkt man auch daran, dass es ethisch komisch ist, vielleicht. Ja klar, auf jeden Fall, wenn man das Tier zu sehr erkennt, dann ist es immer unangenehm. Plötzlich ist es nicht mehr so geil, plötzlich will man das nicht mehr essen. Weil ich finde, je mehr man erkennt, so Geschmacksknospen oder sowas auf der Zunge, oder je mehr das Fleisch so Textur hat und so aussieht wie etwas, was man schon mal gesehen hat an lebenden Dessieren, das ist dann sofort. Ja, also die Tatsache, etwas zu essen, was normalerweise schmeckt. Weil ich denke mir, also ich würde ja ich würde ja die Zunge
nicht lecker machen, oder?
Weil die Zunge muss ja
selber lecker
spüren, das ist ja so eine Art Sensor
für Leckerheit, aber die selber
ist ja dann nicht lecker, oder? Also
verstehst du, wie ich meine, das ist ja die Aufgabe.
Schmeckt dann
Wie schmeckt das, was schmeckt?
Was schmecken kann. Was schmecken kann.
Weil du, ja, ich finde das
ein Paradox.
Ich finde das merkwürdig, das zu essen,
weil...
Es ist wie an Nasen
zu riechen. Niemand würde
ich rieche gerne, ich bin
ein Geruchsmensch. Ja, genau.
Aber ich würde niemals an Nasen
riechen. Ja, vor allem, warum sollten Nasen gut riechen? Ja. Weil sonst würden die das nicht ja selber riechen immer. Du kannst ja eine Zunge, wenn die gut schmeckt. Andererseits, man guckt sich die ganze Zeit in die Augen. Menschen starren sich förmlich die Augen weg. Man guckt sich gerne in Augen. Aber es ist auch eine Bedrohung. Gewinnst du oder verlierst du im Blickduell? Angenommen, es kommt so ein bisschen unangenehmer, sehr breitbeinig gehender, aggressiver Mensch auf dich zu. Ach so, nee, nee, in jede Form von Aggression. Nee, nee, immer sofort unterwürftig. Stared you down. Immer direkt auf den Rücken legen, Bauch nach oben und Hände in die Luft wählen. Einfach so, ich bin dein, du kannst mich töten, ich bin keine Gefahr für dich, kein Problem.
Ja, same.
Nee, absolut, nee.
Nee, weil das merkt man schon, finde ich, dass so eine Urangst in mir drin ist,
wie so ein Instinkt getriebenes Ding.
Habe ich jetzt auch gesehen, wenn man Babys auf Gras, langsam auf Gras setzen will,
machen sie die Beine hoch, weil so ein Instinkt in ihnen drin ist, dass sie Angst haben vor Gras oder Wiesen oder so. Man kann es nicht mehr so sagen, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass es, weil so ein Instinkt in ihnen drin ist, dass sie Angst haben vor Gras oder Wiesen oder so. Die haben Angst vor Wiesen? Ist das eine gute Idee? Man kann Kinder nicht, wahrscheinlich so Urangst, man weiß nicht, man sieht den Untergrund nicht, man sieht nicht, sind da Schlangen, sind da Ameisen, man sieht es nicht. Man kann Babys nicht auf man kann Babys nicht auf Gras setzen. Oh Mann, manchmal sagt man auch, Körper entspann dich. Ja, eben. Wir leben nicht mehr in einer Welt, wo man ständig sagt, oh, der Boden ist schlangen, der Boden ist schlangen. Hey, wir sind in einem Familienhaus, im dritten Stock, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie eine Schlange gesehen und der Körper so, Alarm, Alarm, Schlangenalarm, Schlangenalarm, hey, ganz entspannt. Das ist eine Dreifachsteckdose, entspann dich einfach. Kein Problem, ja. Ja, aber Babys sind auch Panik, Panik, Panik. Und bei mir ist es ja, man sieht es ja, man hat sich ja sehr viele Instinkte abtrainiert oder spürt man gar nicht mehr so. Aber wenn mir ein gefährlich aussehender Mann mich niederstarrt auf der Strasse, habe ich diese Angst definitiv. Fühle ich mich bedroht und gucke ich weg. Absolut, ich bin devot, ich lasse mich überfahren, übergehen. Ich habe letztens auch, glaube ich, den absolut archetypischen Autofahrer gesehen und ich liebe das ja, wenn so gewisse Konzepte so prägnant in der Realität vertreten sind, wo du wirklich sagst, wenn ich jetzt ein Videospiel machen würde, also so Mortal Kombat-mäßig, wo Becker gegen Zahnarzt antritt, dann brauchst du ja den Klischee Becker, die Inkarnation des Beckers und die Inkarnation des Zahnarztes, damit der Gamer checkt, ah, okay. Und ich hab wirklich den Archetypen des Autofahrers gesehen, und zwar schön ein Arm schön aus dem Fenster raus, damit das Lenkrad gehalten, in der rechten Hand zwischen Zeige und Mittelfinger die Zigarette und Hand auf der Hupe. Also in der rechten Hand Zigarette und Hand auf der Hupe schon die ganze Zeit und einfach jeder wird aus dem Weg gehupt, Ultrastress, mein Fahrer hier! Die ganze Zeit und wirklich Reissverschlusssystem, man wechselt sich ab, der ballert vor mich und ich, okay, ich bin hier unterlegen, du bist Autofahrer Level 100, du hast es durchgespielt, ich bin gerade in der Anfangsquest Level 12. Und du hast morgen einen Herzinfarkt. Genau, dein Stresslevel, dein hohen Blutdruck und die Zigarette lassen, einen darauf schließen, dass du morgen einen Herzinfarkt hast. Ich finde das so geil, weil für mich ist die Hupe wirklich, das benutze ich einmal im Jahr, vielleicht. Nee, ich habe so oft die Hand. Und der wirklich einfach, das ist die Standard-Handhaltung, also Lenkrad, Pedal, Hupe, das ist wirklich die Standard, das ist die Tastenbelegung. Ich fahre manchmal so. Nee, ich habe mein Leben noch nie gehoben. Boah, ich doch, ich prob die ganze Zeit, ich hube Leute aus dem Leben raus. Ja, ich glaube, du bist schon weiter. Ich bin sogar als Beifahrer so unangenehm, hasse ich mich selber, dass ich Leuten ins Lenkrad greife und hupe. Ist immer richtig, ja. Wenn mir jemand auf die Nerven geht. Wow, okay, das ist wirklich. Doch, wenn mir jemand auf die Nerven geht und so richtig doof fährt, so richtig bescheuert fährt. Ich finde, man muss sich an Grundregeln halten, das ist saugefährlich. Wenn Leute sich dumm anstellen im Verkehr, es ist saugefährlich. Okay, aber die Beifahrerregel, nicht einmischen, schlägt alles andere. Der Beifahrer hat sich nicht ein... Der Beifahrer kriegt das Autoradio und ansonsten nichts. Es gab neulich eine Situation, wir fahren, ich bin der Beifahrer, wir fahren und es gibt zwei gerade Ausspuren und eine Rechtsabbiegerspur. Und wir waren in der Mitte und der Typ auf der Rechtsabbiegerspur ist auch geradeaus gefahren. Und es waren vorne zwei Spuren, riesige grosse Kreuzung, vorne gab es zwei Spuren, drei Autos fahren drauf, der sieht uns nicht und fahren und der andere war auch weirdly weit rechts und dann sind beide so, haben uns so in die Mangel genommen und ich habe ins Lenkrad gegriffen, laut gehupt und dadurch haben beide geschnallt, oh shit, da wird gerade ein Auto eingequetscht von uns verdammt nochmal. Und beide haben gecheckt, das geht gerade nicht. Sonst wäre es passiert. Und ich gebe dir recht. Aber kannst du es nicht über das Autoradio lösen? Kannst du nicht irgendwie taktisch in dem Moment den Sender wechseln? Du hast recht. Weil jeder, jeder Partei hat. du musst deine Bedürfnisse auch mit den Medien ausdrücken, die dir zur Verfügung stehen. Nicht jeder hat die gleichen Art von Medien zur Verfügung. Als Beifahrer, du hast die Helligkeitsklappe oben und du hast das Autoradio.
Deine eigene, auf jeden Fall.
Nee, ich habe auch schon negative Erfahrungen gemacht mit Beifahrern.
Ich weiß noch, da sind wir zum Kino gefahren und das war ein Film, der nicht in jeder Stadt lief, deswegen mussten wir in eine andere Stadt fahren.
Und dann war es so.
Avengers Endgame.
Und dann war es so, halt relativ knapp bemessen die Zeit, wann das Kino war.
Und dann meinte der Beifahrer so, kannst du nicht so 10 kmh schneller fahren, ich glaube wir verpassen den Film. Und dann habe ich wirklich den Rest der Fahrt in meinem Kopf wirklich versucht zu rechnen, wie viel schneller wir jetzt am Ziel sind, wenn wir jetzt statt 110, 120 fahren. 10 Kilometer die Stunde. 10 kmh. Ja, 10 Kilometer die Stunde ist eigentlich schneller. 20 Kilometer weg, also kommen wir zwei Stunden. Moment. Zwei, 20 Kilometer. Flur und es ist grün. Währenddessen sieht man so das Auto, fährt so immer weiter nach links, immer weiter nach links und kratzt so an der Leitplanke und ich so, 10, Moment mal, also 100, 10, denk doch mal nach, das kann ja nicht so schwer sein.
Und dann so, sie hat einen Autounfall, sie hat einen Autounfall, kurz einmal in die Lampe gucken, bitte, in die Lampe gucken.
Wenn wir um 18 Uhr losfahren und der Film beginnt um 19.30 Uhr. Sie hat einen schlimmen Autounfall, Herr Will. Ja, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, w Uhr. Sie hatten einen schlimmen Autounfall, Herr Will. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Wenn jemand sagt, wir rechnen alles in Meter pro Sekunde um, okay? Wir rechnen alles einfach mal um, okay? 110. Einfach keine Chance. Ich habe es nicht geschafft. Und ich erinnere mich, ich habe es sogar im Film, während des Films noch gerechnet, weil ich mir dachte, ich finde das ist so eine merkwürdige Aussage, fahr 10 kmh schneller, als ob Superbrain jetzt berechnet hätte, dass wir genau jetzt noch leicht die Geschwindigkeit ändern müssen. Und Schatz, wie hat dir Cast 2 gefallen? Es ist doch mal 3,6 oder geteilt durch, warte, kmh auf Meter pro Sekunde, war geteilt durch oder mal 3,6?
Nee, aber jetzt möchte ich auch, jetzt habe ich das nämlich auch gerade, der RAM-Prozessor ist auch angegangen bei mir, weil ich jetzt auch denke, aber wie viel Spaß du.
Das ist so Micromanagement, einfach so Fahrzehn. Und da habe ich gesagt, Beifahrer nie wieder.
Beifahrer nie wieder oder setz dich hinten oder halt die Klappe. Wirklich, das ist dann die Regel. Aber hinten kannst du auch sehr nah ran. Von hinten kannst du dich nach vorne drehen und ins Ohr sagen, wenn du zehn Minuten Klappe stehst, dann kommen wir 4,8 Minuten früh an. Ja.
Nee, ich bin eh mittlerweile, glaube ich, an einem Punkt in meinem Leben,
wo ich gerne schon die Regeln formuliere, bevor es zur Katastrophe kommt.
Ich bin, glaube ich, mittlerweile auf AGB-Niveau.
AGB macht es richtig.
AGB sagt, hey, pass auf, du willst hier ein Abo abschliess mit mir?
Kein Problem, okay?
Aber hier sind meine ...
Danke, Florian, dass du mich nach Hause fahren kannst heute. Supercool, vielen Dank, dass aber hier sind meine Bevor du einsteigst. Klar. Das ist mein Auto und ich nehme dich mit. Und falls du mal ganz kurz das was dagegen, wenn ich irgendwie den Song anmache, über den wir heute den ganzen Tag gesprochen haben. Africa. Bevor du das machst. Ja, wir hatten wirklich kein guten Gesprächsteam. Vielleicht kannst du einfach mal kurz vor dich in das Handschuhfach greifen. Da findest du ein sechzehnseitiges Dokument. Weil ich muss gleich zu Hause sein. Ist okay, wenn du mich nicht mitnimmst, aber du hast angeboten, dass du mich ... Genau, ein sechzehnseitiges Dokument. Das kannst du dir mal in Ruhe durchlesen. Da steht unter anderem drin, dass du als Beifahrer erst mal die Klappe hältst. Zweitens, wenn wir an der Kreuzung stehen, lehnst du dich nicht nach vorne, um nach rechts zu gucken. Das ist zwei. Das ist zwei. Ja, weil dann kann ich ja nicht sehen. Zwei ist, wie man an Kreuzungen ist. Dann muss ich mich ja noch weiter nach vorne beugen, damit ich an dir vorbeischauen kann. Ja, zum Teil, ich habe es auch nicht gemacht. Weil wir kennen uns kaum, ich werde nicht dir vertrauen, wenn du sagst, da kommt
keiner, weil am Ende bin ich
tot und du nicht
und deswegen, okay,
lass mich schauen. Währenddessen die Arbeitskollegen
sehen das Auto, in dem offensichtlich
geschrien wird und
Florent den will ich ja immer mitnehmen.
Zweitens, du
kommentierst 2b,
okay, du kommentierst nicht die Geschwindigkeit. Okay. Okay, und wenn, dann tu es in einer mathematisch für mich nachvollziehbaren Art und Weise, ja? Du fährst so langsam, du fährst so schnell. Genau, hier ist 60. Ich mach kein Mathe-Rätsel. Du fährst 40. Genau, wenn wir jetzt 10 Kilometer schneller fahren die Stunde, wann kommen wir an, wenn die Strecke 12 Kilometer lang ist? Und erst wenn du die unterzeichnet hast, dann fahren wir los. Ground Rules. Das ist meine neue Art, mit Leuten umzugehen. Warum ist da auch ein See-Palast-Schriftmandat hinten angehängt? Falls wir falsch parken, zahlst du die Hälfte. Ich zahl die Hälfte, wenn du falsch parkst? Wenn du mich eingewunken hast,
nee, das winkt mich einfach gar nicht ein. Okay. Es wird nicht gewunken. Aber du hast auch Rechte.
Du kriegst das Autoradio, du kriegst den USB-Stecker. Okay. Viel Spaß. Okay? Ja, mein Autoradio ist kaputt, ja.
Ist das das Animal Crossing Cover?
Schatz, du hörst mir wieder das Podcast-UFO, oder?
Kannst du es ein bisschen leiser stellen, danke. Die Animal Crossing-Variante. Oder die Chipmunks-Variante von dem eh schon sehr hoch gesungenen Song Afrika von Toto. Toto, oh la la, le Toto vonvana. Genau. Nee, das war es soweit von mir. Okay, gut. Alles klar, dann ist auch mal gut anzukündigen, wenn man einfach fertig ist. Also auch bei so einem Essen oder so. Ja, das war's von mir. Ich wäre durch für heute. Und falls ihr noch Fragen habt, schreibt mir gerne eine Mail oder so. Ich würde jetzt gehen, nochmal alles Gute, Tante Henrike, alles gut zum Godstag, ich wäre durch. Falls niemand mehr was hat, würde ich gehen. Wir haben nichts mehr. Dann muss einer übernehmen von den Freunden, der sagt dann, das war's, von Floris Iwild an dem Abend. Dankeschön, haut rein, habt noch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut, danke. Und wir sehen uns, ciao. Einfach mal, wenn man nichts mehr zu sagen hat, gehen. Einfach mal, wenn man weiß, ich kann ja nichts mehr beitragen zur Konversation, ich gehe einfach. Ich liebe Abmoderation. Die riecht man auch gegen den Wind schon auf 50 Meilen, wenn man 60 Kilometer pro Stunde. Man denkt immer, das sei eine Fähigkeit, die nur Medienleute brauchen, die eine Sendung haben oder so. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, jeder muss abmoderieren. Jeder braucht Abmoderation. Ich meine, die klassische Abmoderation ist natürlich der Schenkelschlag. Ach so. Oder natürlich so dieses, gut, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir für heute. Wie? Und ja, dann, ich glaube, soweit ist alles durch und muss man aber nur machen wenn man wenn du leute rauswerden wenn du leute rauswerfen willst wenn du wo zu besuch bist kannst einfach abends gehen ja du musst nicht abmoderieren bisschen abmoderieren bisschen sagen so ich mache mir jetzt auf die socken mässig wenn du zuhause bist dann musst du diese gross dieses große Theaterstück auffüllen. Dann musst du sagen, so, wir haben es aber echt lange ausgehalten, haben wir uns echt ein bisschen verquatscht, oder? Genau, weil es ist ja schon sehr spät jetzt auch. Hättest du das gedacht, tu immer mit deinem Drecksgraffer, dass dir einmal einen Drink gemerkt, dir das in meinem Restaurant gehört, und dann benutzt du das Wort inflationär. Ach ja, das ist, ich will, ich versuche ja sozialer zu werden, muss ich sagen, irgendwie mal mit Leuten essen zu gehen oder so. Und jetzt kommt Alkohol in den Mix. Und dann wirklich so ein, so, und jetzt machen wir uns noch einen schönen Grapper auf, oder? Ja, okay. Das würde ich gerne mal sagen, ohne es ironisch oder irgendwie lächerlich machen zu meinen, aber ich bin noch nicht da. Nee, ich bin noch nicht an dem Punkt. Nee, nee, verstehe ich auch. Und jetzt noch mal, jetzt noch mal ein schönes Tiramisu für alle, oder? Ja, oder? Machen wir doch. Ich habe noch was im Kühlschrank. Ich habe noch schon was im Kühlschrank. Das ist unangenehm. Ich will das richtig schön. Ich lade dich mal ein. Nee. Aber ich muss jetzt eh leider wieder revidieren, weil ich habe ja, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge triumphierend angekündigt, dass mein Abfluss wieder repariert ist, er wurde durchgeätzt, durchgeabflussrein ist wieder verstopft. Und er ist wieder verstopft. Naja, das ist nicht ganz richtig. Ich habe jetzt mehr Spielraum, bis er verstopft ist. Ich habe jetzt mehr Kapazität, das heißt, ich kann jetzt einmal so zwei Tage den Abfluss normal benutzen und dann ist er wieder verstopft. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen spare, dann kriege ich das einigermaßen hin. So, das läuft schon, aber es ist anscheinend immer noch ein Thema.
Und ich habe jetzt tatsächlich auch, weil ich habe ja vor einigen Folgen mal erzählt, dass ich eine Ohrenkamera habe, wo man sich mit so einem Stiel selber ins Ohr filmen kann.
So, jetzt hast du genug in die Ohren gesteckt, jetzt wird einfach in Abflüsse gesteckt.
Und jetzt habe ich die Ohrenkamera auch mal in den Abfluss gesteckt.
Und ich komme nicht tief genug, weil der Abfluss hat Biegungen.
Aber ist die denn starr, also ist die Biegung das Problem? Die Biegung ist das Problem, das ist sehr kurz, so ein Ohr ist ja nicht so wahnsinnig tief. Und jetzt habe ich wirklich überlegt, ob ich mir wirklich chirurgisches Kameramaterial, so Darmkameras oder so, um wirklich da reinzugehen, weil ich finde es schon spannend, weil man muss ja sagen, ich bin jetzt auch Next Level aufgestiegen, ich habe euch ja allen erzählt, ich hatte die Ohrenkamera und die Ohrenkamera hat ja vorne an der Kamera so einen Stiel dran, mit dem man dann so Sachen rauskratzen kann. Aber irgendwann habe ich in meiner Recherche erfahren, es gibt jetzt die Next Level Ohrenkamera. Ja, also diese Erfindung quasi gerade auf dem Markt, schon ist der nächste Level zu erwarten. Es geht immer weiter. Und zwar gibt es jetzt Ohrenkameras mit einer Zange vorne.
Mit einer kleinen Zange. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr
ein fester Stil, sondern eine Zange. Das heißt,
du hast jetzt wie so ein Ego-Shooter unten so eine Zange.
Es ist ein Minigame. Es ist ein Minigame und du kannst
jetzt hinten am Griff drücken, um die
Zange zu schliessen. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt
auch wirklich Sachen packen und rausziehen,
weil dieses Schabeding, gerade wenn du
tief drin bist, je tiefer du drin bist, desto
weniger Bewegung hast du ja, desto kleiner wird dein Winkel. Das Schabeding, gerade wenn du tief drin bist, je tiefer du drin bist, desto weniger Bewegung hast du ja, desto kleiner wird dein Winkel.
Das Schabeding.
Oh Gott.
Es ist wirklich absolut ekelhaft.
Und jetzt habe ich mittlerweile schon die Next Level, die wirklich teuer war, die jetzt ein gutes Stück teurer war.
Die hast du jetzt?
Weil die musst du aus China bestellen, weil es die nur dort gibt.
Und die habe ich jetzt auch.
Und jetzt dachte ich mir, kann ich die alte Kamera umfunktionieren zur Haushaltskamera und versuche damit jetzt irgendwie den Abfluss zu erkunden. Ich glaube, meine These wäre einfach nur, du hast es nicht lang genug, das hat Wasser nachlaufen lassen, nach deinem Rohrreinigungsversuch, weil danach musst du ja alles durchspülen. Du ätzest es dann so weg und dann machst es so klein, aber es geht auch nicht alles weg, es löst ja nicht den Wohlgefallen auf, sondern es ist ja einfach noch ein bisschen da und das musst du dann rausspielen. Da brennt einem ein bisschen das Herz, weil man natürlich sehr lange das Wasser laufen lassen muss, aber, ne? Du aus der Sanitär-Dynastie-Tize hast du natürlich mehr Erfahrungen, ne? Ich bin da ja komplett überfordert. Ich habe ja gar keine Ahnung von Abflussen und Wasser. Hat man ja normalerweise nicht, ne? Das ist ja gar... Dafür gibt es Profis. Dafür gibt es Profis oder eben dann die Kinder von besagten Dynastien, die sich dann eben auch so oder ähnlich gut auskennen, die dann andere Leute ständig korrigieren können mit ihrer Expertise. Die Sätze beginnen mit Ich als, was immer sehr sympathisch ist, um direkt mal zu markieren, dass man schon unhinterfragt, was besseres ist als der andere. Ich als jemand mit mehr Allgemeinbildung würde dir sagen. Ich als jemand, der mehr Ahnung hat als du, würde dir empfehlen. Schleunigst xyz. Das ist auch ein Wort, das gibt es nur im Superlativ, im Ultimativ,
oder? Ne, Superlativ. Ne, Schleuniger.
Komparativ, Superlativ. Es gibt nicht
Schleun, Schleuniger,
Schleunigst. Schleunigst. Ich weiss gar nicht,
wie die Form Schleunigst
überhaupt heisst. Ist es auch einfach
Superlativ? Hm, weiß ich nicht.
Schnellst, also schnell,
schneller, am schnellsten, aber es gibt noch
Schnellst. Genau, Schnellst. Schleunigst. Weiss gar nicht, was das ist, Schlest, also schnell, schneller, am schnellsten, aber es gibt noch schnellst, schnellst, schnellst, schleunigst, weiss gar nicht was das ist, schleu, schleuniger, am schleunigsten und schnellst auch noch, schleunig ist auch so ein geiles Wort, schleunig, das ist ein fantastisches Wort. Aber steckt da schlau mit drin? Nein, nein, nein. Das ist ja äh, u, oder? Nein, nein. Das ist reine Geschwindigkeit.
Ah, das wollte ich auch noch fragen.
Ich untersuche ja, ich habe ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, ich untersuche Kleinstdialekte in meiner Familie, weil es gibt sehr viele Kleinstdialekte. Da ist sehr viel zu holen bei mir. Superspannend. Und meine Mutter benutzt regelmäßig das Wort Zwitscheduri. Das Wetter, das Wetter ist heute, aber nur beim Wetter. Wie ist oh, es war, wie ist gerade das Wetter bei dir? Mama, wie geht's dir im Urlaub? Ja, ein bisschen Zwitscheduri. Das Wetter ist Zwitscheduri. Und ich finde, man kann es sich selbst, und ich hab das oft benutzt auch, weil ich dachte, es ist normal, alle benutzen das, alle Älter benutzen das. Und meine Mutter benutzt es auch so mit Fremden. Und noch niemals kam eine Rückfrage. Alle verstehen, was gemeint ist mit, oh, es wird das aber ganz schön switche-duri. Lass mich raten, ich würde das jetzt interpretieren als mal so, mal so. Exakt. Okay. Und genau das ist gemeint. Und sowohl durchs englische Switch als auch so Zwischen, was ja auch mit drin ist, wahrscheinlich hast du ja den gleichen germanischen Wortstamm irgendwo, so Proto-Germann, Switch, I don't know, da war ich nämlich gerade, bin ich drin, bin ich tief drin. Die Proto-Germanen haben auch so, ja, Switcher-do, Switcher-do, Switcher-oo. Nee, aber Switch im Sinne von Zwischen oder Switchen, das hat ja auch ... Zwischen und Switchen, ja, okay. Vielleicht kommt es da irgendwo her aus der Ecke, aber man checkt es sofort, deswegen finde ich es gut, es ist nicht googelbar, es gibt noch nicht ein Eintrag für Zwitscheduri. Zwitscheduri. Also es ist sowohl, es ist nicht nur ein kleinst, es ist so ein kleinst Dialekt. Er wird ja auf eine einzige Person beschränkt. Das denn nur, genau. Vielleicht ist es wirklich nur deine Mutter, die dieses Wort sagt, aber alle nehmen es hin. Das zeigt ja auch, wie das Sprache über Kontext funktioniert und aber auch über so Lautmalereien. Das ist ja auch so, man checkt schon, was gemeint ist.
Aber jetzt haben wir schon drei Sachen. Zwitsche Duri, der blanke Montag und etwas auf den Stub bekommen.
Was war denn nochmal der blanke Montag?
Also der blanke Montag ist, ich gehe heute Abend essen. Du gehst essen auf dem blanke Montag? Verstehst du? Auch aus dem Kontext sehr gut. Man kann nicht an normalen, normal-ass-Wochentagen fancy Sachen machen. Aber ich gehe heute ins Phantasialand. Hä, auf dem blanken Mittwoch? Auf dem blanken Mittwoch? Heissend, kein Feiertag, kein Brückentag oder sowas. Ein ungewohnt profaner Zeitpunkt. Genau, ein ungewohnt profaner Alltagstag, wo man arbeiten, wo die Bevölkerung arbeiten geht. Auf dem blanken Montag? Auf dem kalten Donnerstag gehst du einfach weg. Also wir haben den blanken Montag, wir haben Zwitschel-Duri und wir haben auf dem Stub. Ah, das muss jetzt wieder auf dem Stub sein. Das muss jetzt wieder sofort haben. Auf dem letzten Drücker. Nee, nee, ganz so, nee, es muss jetzt sofort sein, ohne nachzudenken. Ach so, auf den Stubb. Ah, ich hätte mir überlegt, ich möchte gerne, ich habe ein bisschen mit Tennis angefangen, ich möchte gerne einen neuen Tennisschläger. Ach, das muss dann wieder auf den Stubb, brauchst du wieder einen neuen Tennisschläger. Wow, okay, das war jetzt Ironie. Der sei jetzt direkt mal ironisch benutzt, also das muss jetzt so schnell wie es geht sein? Genau, so schnell wie es geht sein, ja, auf den Stubb. Flotty brauchst immer auf den Stubub. Also aber negativ dann auch, oder? Also es ist nicht so asap oder so, sondern... Nein, da ist direkt mit drin, das muss aber nicht sein. Florentie braucht immer alles auf den Stub. Okay. Er macht es unnötig schnell, er nimmt sich unnötig wichtig, dass er es jetzt ganz schnell braucht. Das habe ich auch nicht gefunden. Aber ist deine Ironie schon in Stub mit drin? Nö, Abfälligkeit ist mit drin, Ironie nicht unbedingt. Aber muss es jetzt auf dem Stub sein? Da ist keine Ironie mit drin. Das ist einfach nur so ein, das muss aber jetzt nicht so schnell sein. Auf dem Stub ist wie so überstürzt. Ja, überstürzt, ja. Und das gefällt mir, also ich habe schon drei, drei habe ich jetzt schon gefunden. Und ich finde das interessant, Kleinstdialekte. Zwitscheduri, finde ich gut. Vielleicht gibt es Leute da draußen, die das Wort regelmäßig benutzen, man weiss es ja nicht. Eben. Vielleicht gibt's ja wirklich so die vier auserwählten Protogermanen, die getrennt wurden bei der Geburt. Einer davon ist seine Mutter, vielleicht ist es ein alter Stamm von irgendwelchen Kreuzrittern, die, wenn sie zusammen in einem Raum sind, irgendwie den dunklen Herrscher beschwören oder so, wer weiß. Face and Safe World, was jetzt so Leute, so Schlafagenten Oh, das kann auch sein, die wachen jetzt auf. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob ihr das auch kennt. Ich habe es googeln wollen, nicht gefunden. Ich finde es sehr spannend. Gibt es das Wort bei euch? Benutzt ihr auch Wörter, die niemand anderes benutzt? Ich finde, Kleinstdialekte haben eine irre faszinierende Sorge für mich. Da haben wir schon mal viele Einsendungen bekommen, ist auf jeden Fall ein tolles Thema. Und davon benutzt man auch einiges. Ja, ja. Pips, Peln. Diese kleinen Hautfetzen am Finger. Die Pips. Habe ich mir gemerkt und finde ich immer noch nicht schlecht. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Man hat immer immer so kleine Hautfetzen. Wo kommen die denn her? Wohl mit der Haut. Haben wir zu viel Haut? Wir haben zu viel Haut, dann sag's doch. Alles an den Fingernägeln sagt, wir haben zu viel Haut. Raus damit, einfach weg damit. Langsam. Stell dir mal vor, Fingernägel wären die einzige Möglichkeit, für den Körper Exkremente loszuwerden. Oh, bleee. Deshalb, man hätte keine Körperöffnung. Und der Körper muss alles in Fingernägel drücken. Du meinst auch Dreck unter? Alles, auch Dreck, wirklich sämtliche Giftstoffe, sämtliche Fäkalien, alles kann nur durch Fingernägel raus. Und die wachsen dann teilweise, je nachdem wie viel man isst, wachsen dann auch so einen Meter am Tag. Und man muss sie dann immer wieder so wegschneiden, die ganze Zeit. Weil da schön auch wirklich die übel riechende ... Vielleicht eine andere Idee für andere Menschen. Vielen Dank trotzdem fürs Zuhören, fürs Dabeibleiben, für die Stange halten. Naja, da war ja auch viel das Team jetzt dabei. Und das war ja auch viel das Team. Und die Hörer sind natürlich auch immer wahnsinnig wichtig. Ohne euch wäre das so nicht möglich. Absolut. Wir machen das ja ... Also von euch kommt ja quasi alles. Und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank das Team. Das könnte jeder von euch machen. Es geht nur darum, dass ... Es muss ja irgendein Name draufstehen. Ja, genau. Haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und bis dahin bleibt uns kaum was anderes übrig, als noch zu sagen.
I guess it was a burst-wurst production.